الاوسط ذكرناها قبل قليل تفضل
جوني كما هو واضح وبات معلوما محمد قبل
نحو ساعه من الان استهدفت مسيره اسرائيليه
بصاروخ هذه السياره التي كانت تمر في بلده
كفرا وبلده كفرا هي بلده خلفيه اذا صح
التعبير ليست من البلدات الحدوديه
المباشره عند الخط الحدودي وهي تبعد نحو
10 كيلومترات عن المنطقه الحدوديه كانت
هذه السياره تمر على مقربه من حاجز للجيش
اللبناني لحظه استهدافها ما ادى بطبيعه
الحال الى اندلاع النيران فيها والى اضرار
في هذه المنطقه واضرار في السياره
والسيارات المحيطه وكما استمعنا بحسب
المصادر الامنيه اللبنانيه حتى هذه اللحظه
الحديث هو عن شهيدين وخمسه جرحى جراء هذا
الاستهداف الاسرائيلي الذي حصل قبل نحو
ساعه من الان يمكن القول انه في الاونه
الاخيره بات الجانب الاسرائيلي يلجا الى
هذه السياسه سياسه س استهداف السيارات من
خلال المقاتلات الحربيه والمسيرات الحربيه
يوم امس كان هناك استهداف لسياره على
مقربه من مدينه صور هنا في الجنوب
اللبناني وكان في داخلها احد عناصر حزب
الله بالاضافه الى مدني وبطبيعه الحال
قضايا جراء هذا الاستهداف الاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه لم تقتصر على هذه العمليه
التي تمت في بلده كفره بل ايضا على
الغارات التي نفذتها المقاتلات الحربيه
وتحديدا باتجاه القطاع الشرقي نحن نتحدث
عن سلسله من الغارات التي استهدفت م بلده
مركبه والمنطقه المحيطه بها ما ادى الى
اضرار ايضا في المنازل في تلك المنطقه
بالاضافه طبعا الى القصف المدفعي المستمر
منذ ساعات الصباح باتجاه اكثر اكثر من
بلده ومنطقه في الجنوب اللبناني في القطاع
الغربي والقطاع الشرقي والقطاع الاوسط
بالاضافه طبعا الى العمليه الوحيده التي
اعلن عنها حزب الله وحتى هذه اللحظه وهي
باتجاه سكنه banet